those parts where there was still
progress and where things were were
still getting better also Were Somehow
distracting us from the lack of progress
everywhere else the ways in which we're
not a progressive Society we use the
word Progressive gets used all the time
but it doesn't stand for actual progress
and you know I always say you know the
the uh the the iPhones that um you know
distract us from our environment also
distract us from the way it's strangely
old so you're looking at an iPhone while
you're riding 100 year old Subway that's
completely busted in New York and so
there's something about
um we have some elements of progress but
they've they've been uh distracting us
from you know the lack of progress or
even the outright decline
I'm Dave Rubin live from the local
Studio here in Miami and joining me
today is the founder of the teal
Foundation the co-founder of PayPal and
palantir Peter Thiel I could have given
you like a whole bigger intro there
anything else you want to throw in here
it's all good generally the shorter the
intro the more flattering it is yeah
super long you have a 20-page resume for
people who've never done anything so I
was going to say
disgruntled libertarian something the
longer the intro gets the the more it
suggested you're not really doing
anything at all oh all right well you
are doing a lot I have I actually have
notes I never have notes when I do a
show but I was like I want to cover some
new ground and not just get into the the
political thing that we're always
fighting uh with everybody about but I
thought I'd start because we are here in
Miami uh you know you famously left San
Francisco moved most of the operation to
Los Angeles you do have a place in Miami
um how do you feel about this sort of
movement of people across the country
right now and and sort of watching
people migrate to different places to
live very very different ways well it's
uh it's it's it's it's it's truly a very
healthy thing that uh you know it's it's
uh it's in retrospect it's amazing that
people were as stuck as they were in the
places they were they were in for for
such a long time and you know the the
history of the U.S was that this had
always been a society where people moved
a lot between places and and the
mobility
um the physical Mobility had actually
gone down probably a lot for the last 40
or 50 years relative to the you know 200
year history before that and so uh and
you know it's it's probably the jury is
still a little bit out whether this is a
temporary or permanent feature but it's
it's it's surely a healthy recalibration
it's sort of this idea you can always
start over in this country
um and one of the ways you start over is
you move to a new place where you kind
of patting yourself on the back that you
were the first guy out of San Francisco
and my audience is well aware as I've
posted some videos from a recent visit
to San Francisco the way that place has
just collapsed under Progressive
policies is is absolutely insane I'm
guessing you don't have any employees
that are wishing that you guys had
stayed although you still do have some
people there right there still are some
people not not very many that still are
are living in San Francisco uh proper uh
and uh yeah it is it is really
extraordinary I lived I lived in San
Francisco from
2003 to 2000 2018
and it's sort of you know never quite
got better but the idea it took a while
for the Eddie to sneak up on people that
it was actually on the slow Decay
deterioration thing you know the
homelessness was always a chronic
problem but in circa 2014 2015 you
started to realize you know it's
actually getting worse and they're never
gonna it's not just that this is this
fake problem that they're taking a long
time to fix it's they are it's a fake
problem they used to distract from
everything else they're never going to
fix it so when you when you're here it's
also a real problem well it's also right
it's it's clearly a real problem but
something that they either don't seem
interested in fixing well what do you
think
what they're not interested there are a
lot of problems that are both real and
fake yeah so the homeless problem is you
know yeah it's a it's a it's an
incredible problem but um it's also you
get a sense that it never gets fixed and
so if you if you talk about a problem
that you're never going to fix then you
can avoid talking about all the other
problems like let's say cost of living
for
um out of control rents for people with
homes or broken schools or you know
crime or you know there's sort of are
probably half a dozen other issues that
uh move to the bottom of the queue as
long as we talk about an unsolvable
problem when you were there were you
trying to talk to them about those
things and say guys like look at what is
happening here and and and the state of
the Decay well on the on the on the city
level it felt it felt like uh exit is
much more powerful than voice yeah you
know it is uh it was uh I'm not sure
it's super corrupt but uh uh San
Francisco is super ideological in this
uh very left-wing very uh unreformable
way and uh and uh no it would be you
know it's it's I always have a
schizophrenic view about getting
involved in in politics where it's like
super important and super toxic but uh
but getting involved in San Francisco
San Francisco city politics uh that
would be that would be absolutely an
insane thing to do relative to just
moving you're not enough of a masochist
for that it's it's uh you know I'm I'm
heroism's good martyrdom not so good and
uh and uh and yeah the the relative uh
the relative sanity of getting involved
in local politics or just moving out of
San Francisco you should always move so
to that point one more thing on this uh
so now you're here in Florida you know
yeah
so you're split in time and obviously
you also have your place in LA but do
you feel a real tangible difference when
you're here I mean you know I left a
year ago and it's like I have not looked
back and I'm loving it here and I see
something so incredibly uh powerful and
flourishing here do you feel that when
you're here uh well it has you know
there is there is sort of just an
extraordinary difference if you're in a
place where where you just feel it's
growing versus not yeah and there
there's a sense in which uh Florida
Texas have this um have this Dynamic of
where it's just growing you know every
every storefront is full there are no
empty stores you know everything it's
not I'm not sure it's quite booming but
it feels you know it feels healthy and
growing and then um and then you know
much of California does not quite have
that feel even though of course you know
silicon Valley's been this odd place
where it was a um you know gold rush and
everyone was depressed yeah even so for
the last decade so the the Silicon
Valley had a very odd Dynamic whereas a
crazy boom that didn't actually feel
that way if you you know walk down the
street and then uh and then certainly
with the Kobe chalk the last few years
uh it's quite different I still think
California is is probably somewhat
healthier than New York or you know
completely bankrupt States like Illinois
or you know non-states like Puerto Rico
why do you think healthier than New York
I think um I think the I think there are
ways that the the finance industry that
New York is centered on is more movable
than the tech industry in California
and probably the very big tech companies
like Google and Apple
it's it's hard to picture them actually
moving out of California whereas you can
you can pick you can picture the big
Banks gradually moving out of New York
and certain and and there's something
about Finance that's been a little bit
more movable it also paradoxically makes
it more dangerous for California because
um if things ever go wrong
they will be so bust really like it'll
be like Detroit which thought that it
had these captive big three car
manufacturers and uh could get away with
very bad policies in Michigan Detroit
for decade after decade and then when
you know when that industry finally went
South you know it was it was just
unflexible so do you find that New York
New York's in a worse shape right now
because people are are you know
relatively more people are leaving it's
easier for the businesses to leave
um and then maybe uh maybe California if
it if it's not careful you know it will
at some point really go off the cliff
right do you find that these things sort
of happen slowly and then very quickly
so something like California it's like
you know Cali's lost almost a million
people in these last three years and a
lot of them are high earners I mean
these are people who are paying into the
system that's ever growing at some point
somebody has to look at numbers right
and be like none of this works or I
guess maybe not right it just continues
somehow I suppose yeah I I actually I
don't know how many of them were the
highest earners in California the last
last years I think New York was was a
little bit more more that effect than
than California but yes these things you
know we have these odd Dynamics where
things go on for a very long time
they're not ultimately sustainable but
you know you know there's some there's
some way I often think that much of the
2000s and 2010s
were this weird continuation of the
1990s you know the decades there were
things that happened you know you had
911 you had the global financial crisis
Trump election brexit there were some
events that happened in those 20 years
but it was surprisingly little December
2019 I was reflecting on the 2010s and I
I realized there have been no
retrospectives on this decade what
actually happened in the 2010s you know
we had marijuana legalization we had
Game of Thrones and people fell into
their iPhones and uh and then uh but
then it was somehow just this this thing
that was sort of a stretched exhausted
version of the 2000s which themselves
were stretch exhausted version of the
90s and then uh and then I I want to say
that in some sense you know March 2020
when cobit hits
um we finally you know uh a lot of these
things finally accelerated so and you
know um and uh we're finally in the 21st
century so that's actually a great segue
to sort of where I wanted to start today
because years ago once in off camera you
said to me I wouldn't be a Libertarian
if any of it worked and I just thought
that line pretty much captures so much
of what's Happening even right this
moment we referenced the last three
years of covered where it seems like
nothing really works anymore our
government kind of doesn't work our
educational institutions don't seem to
work the the medical field doesn't seem
to work
is it all is it sort of obvious that
they were all not going to work at the
exact same time or how did this happen
well I'm you know I'm tempted to say the
rod has been building up for a long time
uh and you know if you Define technology
as doing more with less
um so many of these institutions
educational even Health Care are are
kind of the opposite where you get the
same for more or you get less for more
so it's the anti-tech definition the
public schools probably in some sense
the quality of the education is is way
lower than it was 50 or 60 years ago the
costs are way higher and so it's it is
you're getting less for more and uh and
then there are you know versions of us
this with Healthcare where maybe maybe
people are getting a little bit better
health care than they were 30 years ago
but at Double the cost so it's again uh
you know a lot of it's sort of like a 80
socialist Health Care system that we
have not 100 but but 80 and there's a
lot of a lot of stuff that's super up
with that so yeah I think I think there
are a lot of things that had not been
working for for quite some time and
maybe the the interesting question is
why people weren't noticing it or
something like that yeah so what do you
think that is is that just our modern
lives we're staring at our phones all
day we're watching TV shows and we're
just not paying attention
there were still some parts of our
society where things were progressing
and there was certainly some
um maybe narrow cone of progress around
computers software internet mobile
internet
um and then um those parts where there
was still progress and where things were
were still getting better also Were
Somehow distracting us from the lack of
progress everywhere else the ways in
which we're not a progressive Society we
use the word Progressive gets used all
the time but it doesn't stand for actual
progress and you know I always say you
know the the uh the the iPhones that um
you know distract us from our
environment also distract us from the
way it's strangely old so you're looking
at an iPhone really writing a 100 year
old Subway that's completely busted in
New York and so there's something about
we have some elements of progress but
they've they've been distracting us from
you know the lack of progress or even
the outright Decline and then um and
then together with some kind of crazy
crystallizing event like like kobit
where you know you have
no science no rationality
um you know you can't it takes a long
time to even get the vaccine approved
you know the FDA is just a blocker all
these things you know don't work that
well they still work relatively better
in the US than many other countries but
uh but all sorts of things are really
off so as the guy that was the first
outside investor in Facebook and sort of
you know at the beginning of the of the
tech boom 20 something years ago were
you thinking about some of that then or
was anyone talking about the fact that
we might all get distracted by so much
information and so much nonsense and
scrolling and all this stuff that
everything else will just kind of slide
away and we won't even know like was
there any inkling of some of that well I
did I did I didn't you know I I think
it's always a little bit unfair to to um
put too much of the blame on on Silicon
Valley for this where um you know there
was some innovation in Silicon Valley
there was a sense in which it probably
was not not quite enough you know there
was a this Manifesto that um my Venture
Capital fund put out in back in 2011
where the tagline was you know they
promised us flying cars and all we got
was 140 characters and that wasn't it
wasn't meant as an anti-twitter argument
per se like Twitter you know it's a good
business it's good for the several
thousand people that worked there maybe
there were slightly too many but yeah um
for at least for the several thousand
that are left it's a good business it's
uh
um and you know it somehow was
transformative in some way but it's
wasn't enough to you know take our whole
civilization to the next level and this
was so so I think Silicon Valley was was
doing some things but it was not enough
and then you know there were arguments
that you know it didn't have to all be
in Silicon Valley you know they were
building they weren't building flying
cars in Silicon Valley they weren't
building playing Carlos anywhere else
right so since you mentioned Twitter
let's just do an Elon thing for a second
as you watch the guy buy this thing
obviously you guys did PayPal together
and everything else do you think he
realized what a freaking headache this
thing was going to become and and how
how crazy the product under the hood
actually was
there was probably
there was probably uh I I I I'm I've
been talking about the the Twitter
um the Twitter acquisition I think that
uh
or just broadly speaking figure finding
that so many of these things are sort of
broken under the hood in a way
I I think I think he had some idea but
probably not not the full extent yeah
right there was probably you know
probably the fact that they're willing
to sell Twitter to him should have told
him they were just I mean it was just it
was just you know Jack Dorsey all these
other people it was you know they were
just these figureheads and it was I mean
the inmates were running the Asylum yeah
and uh and it was it was probably on
some level
you know you know there was some part of
it that was somewhat ideological there
was a way that uh Elon felt like the
wrong person ideologically to take over
Twitter but I mean after after a decade
of the stock going nowhere they were
just completely exhausted yeah you can
only lose money for so long I don't know
that much about business but they didn't
lose money but they didn't if you look
at the Twitter price the day
at the end of the first day of trading
so you know price the IPO it closes on
day one and I forget what the exact
number was oh I think it was it was
roughly the same right it's roughly the
same as at the point where Elon offered
to acquire it so it had gone nowhere in
a decade in a context where a lot of
tech stocks had gone up so I think they
were they were just completely exhausted
and and it was sort of a plea for help
and then Elon probably on some level
realized it and Ensemble didn't realize
quite how you know please take this
company from us and uh and you know you
can hear that as uh Elon you're
wonderful you can do a great job or uh
we're just really really exhausted right
probably with some combination of both
right so all right so let's shift a
little bit I want to talk to you one of
the things that we've covered an awful
lot on my show in the last two months is
is a lot of the the globalist stuff and
the wef and the meetings in Davos and
all of these things and I always try to
say when I'm doing these things on the
show it's like I I don't have a full
sense of how much influence these
organizations actually have versus is
just they give these crazy speeches we
all kind of freak out about it but what
are actually the policies and then on
the other hand you see someone maybe
like a Justin Trudeau who seems like he
really is incorporating a lot of the
policies of the wef so as someone that
you you've been to some of these things
over the years right like what do you
make of what actually goes on there I
assume you're usually kind of on the
outside even if you're there yeah just
because of your political leader I I
went to the wef three times 2008 2009
2013. so I haven't been in about a
decade
um
it is
I mean there's things about it that are
maybe maybe talking some about global
globalism generally
um it is it is somehow this official
ideology it is
it's in some ways very exhausted so it's
I think the tide is going out the high
Watermark year was probably 2007 and
it's been going out in some way for 16
years but it's been going out very very
slowly and um and there are sort of ways
that uh it is um you know in theory
um you know a borderless more integrated
more peaceful world is is a good world
for the 21st century that's good
globalization right and then there are
all kinds of versions of it that are
kind of bad where it just ends up being
you know a a racket for
um you know dictators stealing money and
stashing it in Swiss bank accounts which
probably were Davos you can think of as
a sort of reputation laundering
operation or something like that yeah or
they're all sorts of versions of it that
are you know um uh deeply deeply
unhealthy and I think it has been on
this this kind of autopilot where it
just keeps going even though it's very
exhausted I think it's been exhausted
for for 15 years is that why in some
ways the the rhetoric seems to ramp up
where you know they really are making it
sound like we control you and we are the
gods and it's sort of like hysterical
because perhaps there actually isn't I
mean that would be I I would love that
as the takeaway here yeah there probably
are all these
different vectors of globalization
there's you know trade is the movement
of goods movement of people is sort of
immigration policy
um movement of money is is banking and
finance and um and then um movement of
ideas is the internet and so there's
sort of a those you can sort of analyze
it in terms of these these uh these
different sectors uh and there were in
theory all these ways these things
should work in theory you know free
trade is is a positive sum exercise
where both sides benefit and I think was
you know Adam Smith who said you know
why would anybody ever throw rocks in
their own Harbor and and uh and then you
know um being able to to move
you know between countries and places is
also something that you might expect to
see in a dynamic healthy world so there
are are sort of all kinds of ways these
things are in theory pretty good and
then in practice they went they went
very Haywire the movement of money piece
was in some ways the global financial
crisis where people were um sending the
money to all these different places all
over the world where they had no local
knowledge and um and uh it was badly
invested and then the banks blew up and
that so that you can think of 2008 as as
the financial part of globalization kind
of blew up so then and then you know one
version would be well it's going to just
stop and we're going to stop sending the
money
and it sort of got replaced by
governments so if you think about
um Europe the sort of a mini
globalization in the form of the
European Union the EU and and basically
in 2007 German Savers were voluntarily
buying Italian bonds and sort of this uh
International Financial flows after 2008
nobody wanted to do that anymore but the
northern European government stepped in
and started doing it and somehow kept
that game going for for another decade
or so but yeah my intuition is that it's
very exhausting there's obviously a
China version of this where you know um
in 2007 people still talked about
globalization as you know all the
developing countries they were going to
converge with a developed world and it
was sort of there's a sort of
Convergence Theory of history and
um in some ways
um that story got dominated much more by
by China and there are you know there
are sort of there are ways in which
China has been growing but it's actually
not been globalizing if globalizing
means become coming you know sort of a
a western liberal democracy and uh and
so China is actually you know this place
that hasn't been following that script
terribly well and if the biggest country
in the world
doesn't fit the picture of globalization
at some point to tell you you know the
theory is wrong right so beyond the end
of History theory was a version of
globalization and I always say that you
know
in 2000 you know the end of History
itself
was obviously over uh ended in 2017 when
G becomes dictator for life you know
right so I think I'm pretty I think
Blake Blake Masters who you co-wrote uh
zero to one with I think his line on
China was we thought that we would make
China more like us basically by by
having a conversation with China about
what's going on with the world and
instead we became more like China so I
take it you probably agree with that
premise generally it's a very disturbed
it's a
you know it's a it's it has a great deal
of very disturbing truth to it and uh
where yeah there's sort of all this
you know social credit scoring
centralized control obviously
um we're still very far ways off from
China you know I wouldn't want to
move there China China is a lot worse
than China was 10 years ago I mean you
know I think you know I think it was you
know it was a one-party communist state
in 2012 but I don't think it felt as
heavy-handed and as totalitarian as it
does now I mean there's there's I don't
know what the right metaphor is it's
like the cylons and Battlestar Galactica
where they've just been the tech the
tech is just it's like all the
surveillance Tech everyone's being
monitored at all times in all places and
now in a way that they they were not a
decade ago so is is the white pill
version of that that it just can't
sustain itself long enough if you if you
surveil people constantly if you control
everything constantly eventually you
cannot maintain that level of control
something to that effect
there are
um you know there are there are stories
we like to tell where it's just going to
collapse and they're you know they're
also very pessim those are I think those
are too optimistic and then I think
there are ones that are you know overly
um overly
pessimistic where China is just going to
take over the whole world and somehow
it's more efficient or things like that
and I I think both the extreme
optimistic and extremely pessimistic
stories are probably wrong it's
somewhere in between and you know we
have to we we we should not assume it's
going to collapse on its own we need to
think very hard about you know
um you know how we how we um rise up to
the challenge that China represents and
it has you know has all these Dimensions
military technological economic it's
sort of much more multifaceted than the
challenge of the Soviet Union was which
was you know much more uh military and
is ideological when you say we is it
like is it our political establishment
that that we are the ones that are gonna
have to deal with
he's always a very ambiguous word so it
means we conservatives we Libertarians
it means we Republicans we Americans and
we the Western World or we all the
countries that are not China yeah or
maybe we okay right like so but what do
you mean by that like in in a sense
you know there's there's
um there probably is
uh you know there's always a debate
between uh let's say you know uh the the
president Trump's policy was somewhat of
a unilateral anti-tuff on China policy
and uh and there's obviously since we're
a multilateral approach to China is is
more powerful and and better it's also
hard to pull off and and so
multilateralism in theory is good in
practice you have to always worry that
that's uh that's almost like a Chinese
Communist uh decoy attack for their
potentially encouraging us to be
multilateral because they know that will
go super slow right basically like
having the UN do anything for the WTO or
all these all these multinational
agencies that that have been you know
semi hijacked so uh so yeah but I think
yeah I think there are there are ways in
which uh
yeah one should start with rethinking it
on on a on a U.S level and then and then
and then uh it's it's definitely
something we need to bring our allies
into do you think we have enough sort of
not mental Acumen but do we have enough
like juice left in America to to tackle
things properly I think I think that's
what a lot of people are feeling right
now that the incompetency is so across
the board and Biden is so either
mentally compromised or has the wrong
ideas or is staffed the wrong way or
whatever you want to call that that we
just don't have enough left to to do the
right thing in the world you know we
um
uh at least as it stands they're always
worries that I that we have that we're
exhausted but I I kind of wonder whether
this is just sort of the baby boomer
narrative where you know the Boomers
were they were this very big generation
and then the country was always defined
by the age the Boomers worse the 1950s
was this innocent childhood time because
the Boomers were 10 years old and the
late 60s was this um great uh youth
movement because the Boomers were all in
college and the 1980s the Boomers were
yuppies and now the boomers are all
retired and angry old people and then uh
or hanging on or and then that somehow
that somehow uh is the template for the
whole us so I you know I think so I
think the complicated answer is there's
some truth to it because the Boomers
have dominated our society and they're
sort of in a in a strange place right
now as a generation
um but uh but they're not the whole
society we're not all Boomers do you
think that's a little bit of
um because people are living longer in
medicine person has been good and
technology has enabled people to be sort
of functional longer that now we're
ruled by octogenarians who you know
basically should you know when you see
Nancy Pelosi up there it's like go go
with your grandchildren go play with
your grandchildren later that you don't
have to be out there still or Biden you
know it's like they can't let go because
science in some ways has kept them going
it hasn't it hasn't changed it it's been
frustratingly slow I mean we've had some
some extension of uh life expectancy
actually reversed the last few years
with covet and the opioid epidemic Etc
but um but I know I think I think the
main the main Dynamic was um you haven't
you never had a generation like the
Boomers you know the I'm you know I'm
Gen X you know there are millennials
um and there's some generational
sensibility you can tell or silent
generation or some generational story
you can tell around other people but the
you know the the generation with a
really strong identity is the Boomers
and I think it's there were just so many
of them it was like in 1946 there were
20 more kids born than 1945 or something
it was like a step function up and then
you get the birth control pill in the
early 60s and you have fewer fewer
babies and and so it was just it was
just a lot of people where does that put
us the Gen xers that seemingly should be
doing the thing right now and I suppose
in some cases we are but but really are
are the missing generation in an odd way
we focus on Boomers and then you know
Millennials or Zoomers or whatever it is
like we've sort of missed the people
that are between say 40 and you know
yeah I have all these resentful genetics
yeah I could say but uh no I think
there's there's probably some narrative
where it's a smaller group and uh and so
there's a risk that you end up being
sort of left out I mean I think there's
some things where we did perfectly fine
I mean we had our we had our share of
you know Olympic gold medalists because
you get those at a certain age and we
were right we're at the right age at a
certain point
um you know it's uh we had 28 years of
of Boomer presidents and I sometimes
wonder whether we're ever going to have
a Gen X present which is just it's not
enough maybe you just skip to the the
Millennials so um you know the Silicon
Valley story in the 1990s was the
internet companies were started by Gen X
people and then somehow bought out taken
over by by Boomers that's sort of what
happened to almost all the companies the
90s and then the Boomers probably had a
healthier relationship with the
Millennials where it was those were the
Millennials were their kids and so they
were they were a little bit nicer to the
Millennials than they were to us we were
sort of more their competitors wow so
yeah when PayPal got acquired by eBay in
um 2002 and it was sort of this Boomer
company and we were this Gen X company
uh one of my one of my friends David
sack said you know
um if it would be a movie we called Meet
the Parents versus this stodgy older
people company was going to clearly not
be fun right when they took over but uh
actually you need uh you need sort of a
word for um for people who are half a
generation older not related to you and
are going to be a lot less nice to you
than your parents
so I think it would be more like um I
don't know Meg Whitman would be like
more meet the um the um the um evil uh
young stepmother right right so actually
since you mentioned sax do you find it
interesting if you were to look back 20
years ago and boy you know elon's doing
everything he's doing now you've done
incredible things you know sax is
becoming an outspoken political voice
you know really anti-war he's one of the
people leading that thing that this crew
of PA you know the PayPal Mafia so to
speak you guys are all still in the mix
in in a odd way is there something
special about what was going on there 20
years ago it was more than 20 years at
this point you know it's it's it's
always hard to uh it's hard to tell the
story it was it was
um
I don't think we really appreciated time
but yeah it was it was a phenomenal
group of people there's always there's
always a sense where PayPal didn't
really succeed in that big a way it was
was a successful exit in 2002 it was you
know one and a half billion acquisition
by eBay but it didn't
you know we couldn't figure out how to
run the business on our own it made
sense to combine it with eBay for all
sorts of reasons it was a you know you
know in some ways a depressing but a
very rational thing to do and then did
you feel that at the time that that
maybe you wanted to hold on a little bit
longer or something like that it it we
didn't it was hard to see a path to an
independent business where you know eBay
you had the store and we were running
the cash registers and the people
running the store were trying to figure
out how to get their own cash register
machines to work and figured it out one
time we'd be sort of out of business and
then there are ways you could gradually
diversify away from eBay and but it took
like a decade in practice so I I think
you know I think I think the combination
made a lot of sense but then it somehow
short-circuited the business whereas you
know so many of the other tech companies
just
scaled and scaled and scaled which was
like the Google history or something
like that and um that would have been
you know far more successful version but
uh probably would have done less you
know if you were if you if you had
um you know if you'd gotten on board the
Google rocket at the right time you
should have just never gotten off right
when you see the the frustrations that
people have with these things you know
the sort of lack of trust in these
things you know is the government
working to silence you on Twitter or how
is Google manipulating the search
results or all of these things do you
also see those as inevitable problem
problems that were going to happen as
these things with these things the
reason I ask is I heard you give a talk
at Madcon you gave the keynote speech
last year and one of the things you said
was that nobody represents the
individual at these big conferences and
I sort of think that's the same problem
that we have with tech nobody represents
the individual anymore we just have
these giant corporations that or these
giant tech companies that make decisions
you cannot get somebody on the phone you
can't you can't actually communicate as
yourself you there is you know there's a
business version of it something like
that yeah there probably are
all kinds of ways they have biases in
that direction you know there's uh
there's always uh Noam Chomsky the
Communist MIT Professor I always like to
quote him on this where he says that you
know the Republicans are the parties the
party of business and but the Democrats
discriminate the Democrats are the party
of big business and um and and there's
sort of like a central left they're
quoting a communist thing
entirely wrong about things or you know
but um but there's sort of a central
left sensibility where
um you know uh basically
big businesses can be regulated they'll
follow all the rules small businesses
you know they often make a little bit
more money by being a gray area not
following the rules to the letter and um
and so there is probably just this
structural anti-small business bias
that's that's uh
you know political regulatory cultural
partisan that's very deep were you
shocked how obvious that became during
covet I mean where you know Target could
stay open for you know the Big Box store
but the mom and pop that was selling the
exact same thing next door got closed
that that shows the bias right there
right the system just kind of eliminated
a certain set of people uh yes I think I
mean I I think it was um yeah I was a I
mean a dramatic shift in terms of the
power of big relative small businesses
and uh it probably I don't know I I
think in some ways covet surfaced all
these realities that had been there for
a long time
and yeah this was this is the
institutional Center left establishment
in this country you know it's it's good
with big business it's it's anti it's
very anti-small business how did you
fight some of that with your businesses
during covet and figuring out you know
were people going to work from home or
just all of the nonsense that everybody
dealt with did you try to give as much
power to your employees and say do what
you got to do or well you know most of
the because even now a lot of the people
still don't want to come back that's one
of the problems that yeah most of the
tech companies were were pretty
um well positioned to adapt to to covet
where you know if you're if you're there
were sort of ways you could do the
remote work
um
you could walk remotely do things like
that uh and it seemingly didn't hurt the
business too much and then of course
there was there was a way where covet
shifted a lot to the Internet so sort of
a lot of the the tech companies in which
I'm involved you know got a got a big
temporary Boost from covid even though
you know maybe they maybe they actually
got you know more bloated less well
managed in the last two three years and
that's that's what I worry about yeah so
it was it was actually sort of a
windfall for them and then the question
is just did they did they really take
advantage of it or or did they get um
even more dysfunctional in various ways
do you think more people in the tech
world or maybe even in the political
world actually think like you to some
degree but because of the way we the
hive mind is or the globalist movement
or whatever it is they just sort of
always go to that but I think you know
if you privately sat down with these
people about what their real beliefs in
the individual are in capitalism and
these things uh directionally yes but I
I think it I always wonder if it
actually works if you can't say it so so
yes the surely almost the definition of
political correctness that it distorts
things and that there are all sorts of
people who are people are less
politically correct than they appear to
be because political correctness is
about appearances and then the reality
is always that people are going to think
it's a little bit crazy you know there
probably are a lot of parents who think
the schools went very crazy but um but
then if you feel like you can't talk
about it or articulate it
it's it's not going to be that
well-formed of you at all and so that's
and so I I think the political
correctness
is is real to the extent it just stops
people from from saying things you you
don't actually get to a very considered
non-politically correct opinion right
it's interesting because that also then
gets to the stagnation part that you're
talking about people can't talk about
what the actual issues are you then you
really don't have to wonder why we're so
stagnated and why we got 140 characters
instead of flying sure there's probably
some way all these things yeah all these
things are are linked but uh but
um yeah I I think
I think if we live in a society where
there are an awful lot of topics that
are somewhat off limits you know where
you know if we think about science I was
let's let's think about sort of
um freedom speech or debate in in the
area of Science and I I always think you
can describe science as involving a
two-front war in theory it should be a
two-front war against excessive
dogmatism and excessive skepticism so
excessive dogmatism in the 17th 18th
century context it's like the Catholic
church or it's the sort of decayed
aristotelianism and you know a scientist
you know needs to think for themselves
and challenge the the
um the sort of ossified uh dogmas or
ossified metaphysics and just do an
experiment you think for yourself
um but then you also can't be a
scientist if you're too skeptical so
that if I don't think you exist I think
you're just a simulation or yeah it's
everything's fake nothing's real I'm
just in a brain being
and I'm just a brain and about being
that's right
that's that's not a good that's not a
good world for science either so you
can't be too too dogmatic you can't be
too skeptical yeah
um and sort of probably a healthy
version of science Cuts against both
excess dogmatism and excess skepticism
but um my scoring is it's all
anti-skepticism at this point uh the
scientific establishment it's all
circling the wagons and we have a
climate change skeptic we haven't you
know you can't be skeptic of you know
you can't be a vaccine skeptic you can't
be a skeptic of of anything and so it's
all against skepticism which is of
course the exact opposite of you know
let's say a children's science book
would be that a science right scientists
thinks for themselves and is is against
dogmatism so what do we do what do we do
to break 80 anti-dog with some 20
anti-septicism that's healthy science
we're in a world where it's 100
anti-septicism and that's a tell that
it's hyper dogmatic and that the
scientists you know the scientists can't
talk freely about the science and if you
have you know if you have if you have
dissenting views you better keep them to
yourself or your government funding will
get cut off and they're you know they're
all in the sort of government welfare or
something like that I mean look at the
last three years of covet and I think
you pretty much yeah there's a
shockingly narrow
range of discourse allowed in science
was there a moment there's another
science and scare quotes right so was
there a moment during covid where where
you realized how disregulating that
effect was that you couldn't get a
counter I mean I saw you a couple times
during covid for for dinners and things
and it was like we weren't wearing masks
and we were sitting there I don't even
know if you were allowed to have people
at your house like but but humans
continued and yet the machine just kept
telling you no stay in your house and
wear the masks and get the vacs and to
do uh I had I had had a lot of
skepticism about all these things before
I would say or the skepticism of the
excessive dogmatism of science yeah and
um
and I think uh I think that had um but
yes I it was it was still it was still
strike it was like you had these uh I
don't know you had these Public Health
officials all these people were it was
just again the opportunity to to Really
um to push it in a conformist
standardized way it was it was it was
extraordinary about it wasn't just the
dogmatism and the uniformity but it was
it was the orwellian character where um
we pivoted radically from black to white
a to not a and so you know it was it was
I I I'm not gonna get the history was so
it was so so many twists and turns it's
hard to even keep it straight but I I
believe October 2020 was still Kamala
Harris saying that she would never take
a vaccine yeah a trump vaccine yeah and
then you know um and then when I I heard
that you literally shouldn't trust the
agencies because he has something to do
with it that's what she said and then
you know and then um a year later it's
it's like you're a really crazy person
if you don't get one so so we had these
sort of orwellian twists in the
narrative you know there was there was
the uh thing where the originally The
Masks didn't work because they were
trying to lie to
save the mask for the hospital workers
or something right and then you pivoted
on that it was you know anyway there was
all these these crazy twists and turns
it was you know there was the initial
the very initial one where um you know
um it was just we shouldn't shut the
border because that's anti-globalist and
then and then when uh when Trump you
know um uh and then when President Trump
didn't
wasn't restrictive enough then somehow
it all shifted into the sort of Puritan
anti-state yeah so it seems like it all
flipped almost I think this is what
you're saying it happened so quickly
that we almost couldn't react like so
the same people who were saying my body
my choice were the same ones yelling at
you that you must be injected with the
thing I want to inject you with and yeah
sort of like it was like you know the
sky is blue but no they were saying the
sky is green and then the sky is orange
and then the sky is yellow so it was it
was it was it was just this dizzying
shift in the dogmas it wasn't like the
Catholic church in the Middle Ages where
at least the dogmas stayed the same for
a few hundred years yeah they don't they
didn't change them like every six months
so what does that tell you I guess this
is a little bit of what you're you're
doing at Stanford now
um what does that tell you about
people's belief systems and and how they
operate
well it's it is uh because they seem to
believe anything on any given day you
could almost depending on who was
president and what their uh you know
party was you could get virtually anyone
to say almost anything
yeah I I would say uh I would I mean
it's hard to do sweeping generalizations
about our society but it's it's uh it's
striking how many things are not very
well thought through at all and there
are yeah I think there are there's some
set of things where things are
doctrinaire and dogmatic and then um
they're all kinds of issues that uh that
barely even register as as problems and
we we don't even talk about so I yeah I
think there's this yeah this official
ideology but it's almost like a magic
show hypnotic trick where you know it
redirects our attention from other
things so so people have yeah they have
very well defined opinions on on the
vaccine and those are sort of officially
set but then if we talk about a topic
like Tech stagnation or how fast are we
developing vaccines generally harvested
curing other diseases besides covid
um that's something people don't even
think about right what what are you
thinking about that maybe the average
person isn't thinking about like if we
if we're to get to the other side of the
stagnation and let's say we start
breaking through some of this stuff
which we will eventually some Society
has to I think uh to some degree
what should we be thinking about
well there are I mean there are there
are a lot of there are a lot of
different topics one uh one one could I
mean I
don't know there's there's some that
I've you know I feel I've I've I've
thought about
um
there's probably a small number that I
always keep coming back to that uh
um but uh I got one I want you to come
back to I'll tell you in a second but I
want to hear you know probably probably
the you know the the the the big the big
one is always just
um you know I don't think our society is
progressing that quickly in that many
dimensions why has it slowed what's
what's gone wrong why has that happened
and that's probably that's probably the
uh the big
topic question theme that I've come back
to over the last two decades over and
over again and uh and then there are
yeah there's all sorts of different
answers one can get to
um there probably are good reasons for
us to be
so slow but I I think it it it it pushes
you out you'd ask a lot of deep
questions about our society that would
be good for us to think about more so
the one that I I don't know if you're
thinking about at all anymore I suspect
you are at least at some level is you
you were really interested in
seastetting a couple probably what 15 or
so years ago this idea that there could
sort of be these libertarian Utopias
sort of international waters where
people could do experimental medication
and operations and things of this nature
to me it feels like so many people have
such a lack of faith in the system that
there's an opportunity there again does
is that registering with you at all is
it do you feel like the operation is
gone has someone else picked up maybe
where you left off they are they are
still trying to trying to do it in
various ways it's uh it's it's not that
easy to do you know there probably are
and some of their technological issues
where it's not that cheap to build right
okay and then and then there are all
these reasons where you know you have to
sort of if you do that you have to if
you have something that's floating
um what if you know you have a freak
storm once every 20 years how do you
model that you know if you have a ship
you can move it out of the way but yeah
she said not so much so it turns out to
be you know it turns out to be
quite hard but what was you know it was
it was sort of the small side project I
started was Milton Friedman's uh
grandson Patrick Friedman who pitched us
on it in I think was 2007 2008
and uh what was surprising to me was how
much it caught fire is you know not as a
technology but just as a thought
experiment because uh
um even if these C studs are very hard
to build
um it was obvious that uh that um if we
could redesign our society we could
somehow start over uh we would do it so
differently and they're all these all
these Legacy structures that are very
hard to undo I mean I don't necessarily
want a total Revolution but but
um they're all these ways that we're in
a place that no one no one would if you
looked at it from first principles no
one would build a society like we have
today so so is there a way to do that
maybe just not doing it by building a
structure in the ocean like finding some
land in the middle of the country and
just trying it at sort of a mic yeah
well there's obviously there's obviously
no there's obviously look there's
obviously this sort of um movement
between different parts of the country
that has been accelerated or restarted
postcovid that that I think is uh very
important very healthy
um yeah and then there are there's still
all sorts of things you can do on a city
county level well it's you know there
were also reasons it was non-trivial you
know uh there are a lot of um a lot of
a lot of cities are unusually
dysfunctional but they also are very
powerful economic networks and so
um there's sort of a reason you know in
a place like San Francisco you know I
lived I lived there for a long time it
was very um dysfunctional on a
governance side but it was you know it
was it was also in the middle of this uh
Gold Rush Tech boom and then uh it
actually it wasn't that it was that you
had um you had this bad governance
sort of in contradiction of the tech
boom it was almost like the bad
governance came with a tech book this is
like people were fine paying this tax
because they were doing so well and so
there's sort of are there are these
natural Network effects these natural
economies of scale that come with cities
but that also paradoxical if you're not
very careful lead to extremely bad
governance and so you know there are you
know there are a lot of relatively
unregulated States but there aren't any
people not enough people there so it's
sort of you know there's a way that
Alaska Wyoming South Dakota New
Hampshire they're all fairly unregulated
but to the extent that um what we do as
human beings as a social component the
sort of networked component um
um they could you could never get the
critical mass of people to move there to
make it work do you sense that the
states will just continue to go their
separate ways that will just sort of see
that and that will be a natural that
it'll actually kind of be okay as long
as they agree not to go to war or
something like that
I I think I think there's uh I think
there's some of it it's I I wish there
were more yeah but uh but I think I
think I know I think that that's that's
probably what's uh what's still
you know very healthy about the US is
that it's it's still
somewhat of a federalist system there's
there still is you know some degree to
which the states are genuinely different
places and uh you have these 50
different experiments and uh and you
it's not all about politics and voting
it's also about you know
economics and exit what do you make
about what's going on culturally in the
country in terms of you know the Super
Bowl was a couple weeks ago I watched
like I'm watching the commercials they
didn't feel I didn't feel any attachment
to any of the cultural references the
halftime show like as Breitbart said you
know politics is Downstream from culture
it seems like we don't have a culture
that's unifying Us in any way now
yeah I I uh it's always it's always so
hard it's always so hard to know exactly
um exactly what's what's going on um
it's probably
you know if there was something that
would be unifying I I don't know that we
would like it that much like it would be
it would be like a crazy woke religion
right and
you know it's I'm always hopeful that uh
the insanity you know has crusted and is
is receding and so uh so yes if we if we
had something that would be unifying it
would be it would be the woke religion
on steroids shoved down everyone's
throats and uh and it's probably it's
probably the fact that it has this sort
of
um not very strong slightly nihilistic
feel may actually be
relatively healthy right that's the
that's the way it may be relatively
healthy so so in terms of better things
for people to believe in so you are can
I say teaching this course are you
actually teaching this course at
Stanford what are you what do you think
I've co-taught yeah courses at Stanford
occasionally over the years it's always
yeah a lot of work but sort of fun
process to think about things and uh
yeah so so what are you doing now
because obviously you don't you don't
need the gig so you're doing this
quarter because you enjoy it we're just
doing
um forbidden topics and this this this
quarter we're doing political theology
which
um means basically what does what does
politics tell us about God and what does
God tell us about politics and they're
both
um these deeply transgressive forbidden
questions I I started I'm starting to
wonder at these questions of religion
are
you know somehow they are I'm not saying
they're necessarily the most important
but they're they are the most
transgressive they're they're the ones
that uh somehow we we can't ask at all
and and there's something there's
something very generative in in looking
at that prison through you know through
a lot of different lenses you know what
what is the religion in our society what
what is the people
um what is the papal Valley in the and
then
yeah how does that work yeah so what
would you say is the sort of broad
answer to that what is the religion of
the people here from an American
perspective right now in a system that
seems to be very obviously shaking to
most people
again it's it's always hard to do these
sweeping generalizations but it is
you know it's in some sense
um
you know it's in some sense I think I
think of it I think of the
the woke
liberal religion as as a as a kind of
antithesis but also kind of
intensification of the judeo-christian
tradition where you know both Judaism
and Christianity
um
um look at it from the side of the
victim if the Jewish people are the
victims in the Old Testament you know
Pharaoh is the oppressor
um
um you know there's way in which Christ
is the victim in the New Testament and
there's there's something that's
very true and very powerful about this
you know reorientation towards
um towards the victim towards you know
Justice against oppression well that's
interesting I think over the course of
thousands of years basically it the the
victim idea was just baked in so so
wokeness is just an extension of that in
some ways and then and then in some in
some weird way it went into you know
hyper overdrive or you know and then
there's always you know the Christian
version is always you know
um it's always it ends up becoming this
competitive thing where people try to be
more Christian than the Christians and
then so you know um you know
um you know the poor shell inherit the
earth Sermon on the Mount and then
um you know told story remarks the 19th
century it's it's it's no we need to you
know we need to actually intensify that
and we need to have a violent Communist
Revolution and accelerate that process
in in this world and um and uh and then
I think I think sort of a lot of
um yeah a lot of uh a lot of the woke
religion can be thought of this as this
incredible intensification of this and
of course you know there are all these
paradoxes where people use their victim
status as a stick which to beat other
people over the head and so there's sort
of all these you know all these all
these Dynamics about it it's obviously
not particularly Christian and that um
you know you still have this um this a
great sense of historical Injustice but
there's no forgiveness yeah right right
there yeah
um yeah it's sort of it's but it's
always this uh it's always this revenge
in the name of you know wronging
injustice how do you find teaching of
course at or co-teaching of course at
Stanford I mean you are one of the guys
that said hey you don't have to go to
college as a matter of fact my producer
here I was having dinner at your house
once and I was like I really want to
hire this guy he wants to go back to
college and you were like you got to
tell them don't go back to college and
it all worked out but but so there's a
little bit of a attention sure there are
all these all these things they do that
are somewhat self-contradictory but uh
it's you know I don't know it's I'm
against Social Security but I'm going to
get a social security check if it's
still around and uh if you know if I was
um you know um if I was you know in a I
if I if I could take advantage of
diversity in hiring I would I would
definitely use diversity quotas to help
myself so um even so I think I think
there's nothing there's nothing
hypocritical about um is that just the
honest version of all of it I mean I
always felt that that was Trump's honest
version of all that they'd be angry at
Trump over taxes and it was like well
don't blame me blame you guys who
created all these stupid rules I I think
I think it's always complicated you know
there are all these yeah they're all
these different dimensions going on but
I think look I think I think the I think
that there is a way that uh that um you
know teaching a course is a terrific
forcing function for me personally to
think about a lot of topics and so you
know I I get a lot out of doing it I
don't read enough books it's so it's a
way to force me to do that on the other
hand in the same breath I can also say
that uh um this doesn't happen in most
other college courses that most of it is
um is sort of this debt-driven racket
that's gone very out of control whereas
300 billion in student debt in 2000 up
to 2 trillion in in 2020 and uh and yes
in the context of this of this larger
system that's uh that's very very broken
so uh so I think and then I think you
know there are there are sort of you
know
um there there's always this Duality
between exit and voice and so there is
you know there is a version where
um yeah it would be good for fewer
people to go to college and for people
to vote with their feet and then uh and
then at the same time there's always
something to be said for uh still trying
to do you know to fight the fight you
know and
I you know I went to Stanford so I have
a certain
um a certain attachment to that
University and you know want to want to
still try to do something on the ground
to make it a better place even though
maybe it's like maybe maybe it's like uh
maybe it's like fighting you know the
the San Francisco
City uh City board or something like
that board supervisors right although
I've told you many times it's a lot more
fun to be in Florida fighting for
something than always fighting against
something which is what I was doing in
Cali which I would imagine there's
probably a time for both of those right
yeah well it's it's
um but yeah it's it's there but I I
think I think we should always
um there's a trade-off between exit and
voice but you you want to think of both
yeah do you think about that I mean just
in general like you can do whatever you
want like you if you wanted to disappear
all together and go to golf not that
easy to do yeah but but you know roughly
Colorado yeah
that's a town right of course if there's
an actual town in Colorado yeah but I
mean do you ever think like it's about a
thousand people live there I thought
just you know buying a bunch of real
estate there but not quite sure uh let
me just ask you one or two other things
um just circling back to some of the
things we covered so we talk a bit about
the globalist stuff in wfml that stuff
when you see this sort of like wide
variance I think between say someone
like like you and Elon who I think are
you know mostly lined up together let's
say and then how that seems so starkly
different than someone like Bill Gates
and yet you guys all seemingly came out
of something
roughly similar does that seem bizarre
to you that that people have evolved so
differently is that the right way to
frame the question you know I uh man I I
um I never want to even compare myself
to Elon that's always a dangerous thing
where you always end up end up losing to
Elon but I think
I would say I am well you guys are
seemingly fighting I am I am just I'm
always disturbed by the degree to which
Tech has become the sort of San
Francisco Silicon Valley
is close to a one-party State yeah and
you know there's a way in which you know
Elon
is a dissident from that at this point
you know I've been I've been a dissident
for for a long time
um and
and um yeah and then what what this but
what this sort of you know strange
Conformity means you know it's it's I
can come up with sociological
explanations you know I'm tempted to do
something like
um
you know the people were
somehow narrowly trained in computer
science which was very um very important
and very useful but then they never
actually thought about most of these
broader social political cultural issues
much at all right and uh and I I you
know I don't know Bill Gates terribly
well but I
um I think he's he's probably fairly
high IQ smart person but I I think he
never really thought about this stuff
very much and then just somehow went
with the wisdom of crowds went with the
liberal consensus right because it's
bizarre that's my sociological
explanation because I can't I I can't
actually right I can't come up with an
explanation how a person would sort of
rationally really get to these these
answers well because I think then you
see people seeing him on TV all the time
and it's like he's the largest farmer
landowner in the United States suddenly
or Farm owner in the United States and
you know he has all this stuff to do
with the vaccines and all these things
and I think most people are like wait a
minute weren't you a programmer 30 years
ago like what happened here that got you
to think you can sort of be you know
king of the world something like that
well there are there are um there are uh
I mean I don't know there are all sorts
of ways you should you should probably
you know be be try to sort of Steal man
what what Bill Gates is doing I mean
there was some place where he made a lot
of money at Microsoft and probably was
not entirely satisfied with that
certainly not with where it was
reputationally for him at the end we
were sort of this you know cutthroat
monopolist
charges and um and uh and then there was
you know this attempt over the last
decade and a half to reinvent himself as
this sort of leading philanthropist and
um and I so I I think you can
I know um and then there are versions
where this was sincere there were
versions where this was just some sort
of rebranding exercise
I think was probably more sincere than
just a just a rebranding but it was
obviously had elements of all these
things sure
um and then uh and then I think yeah I
think there are probably ways one can
also be critical where my my guess is
that he did more good for the world at
Microsoft even even though it was in
many ways you know all these things were
problematic about it as a business but
Microsoft did more good for the world
than the Gates Foundation has done and
and then that's a very odd thing so
that's not what that's not right and I
don't think that's that's interesting
that's not what Gates expected yeah and
um and but it is there's something about
the consensus
um
sort of center-left establishment that's
that is just really exhausted and you
know it would have would have been good
if he he thought about these things
you know with a little bit
you know a little bit less of a
doctrinaire mindset all right so then to
ask you one more question not about Bill
Gates but about yourself related to all
that you've been early on a lot of
things you were early on getting out of
San Francisco and seeing what was going
on there you were early on Trump you've
been early on Plenty of you were early
on Facebook all of these things
right now do you feel do you feel
hopeful do you feel that we can fix a
lot of the things that we've talked
about here and get through the
stagnation and get to a place where we
can trust some people again and that the
system will start working right or is
that a ridiculous exercise I mean your
general state of like belief in the
thing
well it's it's uh I always I always
think you know extreme optimism extreme
pessimism are both equally wrong because
they're both excuses for laziness for
not doing anything and so I think the
answer is always in between yeah you
know as a venture capitalist
I still most of my focus on individual
companies and I think you know there are
a lot of you know there are a lot of
companies that can do quite well even if
our whole society isn't progressing as
quickly as I would like you know on um
you know I think the broader political
social questions it's it's very hard it
is it is it is you know it's just going
to be you know I think a crazy intense
fight for the next decade
um and um you know my my my my senses
that uh my set my my sense is that we're
on this we're on the side I'd want to be
on I'm not sure our side is going to win
but uh but it's it's uh it's it's going
to be much easier to be on our side than
uh than defending all this stuff all
right right it's just it's just there's
so much so much surface area
that they have to defend right and that
does seem like why it gets increasingly
hysterical because they can't defend it
anymore so it's constantly the yeah you
have Litany of lunacy is just you have
to you know you have to if you're gonna
have these massive lockdowns in society
you also have to lock down debate you
have to lock down speech and you have to
uh and that there's probably some
version of it where it's very unhealthy
you know I always you know if you sort
of personalize it in
um in the person of the president sort
of somehow it was a crystallization of
where Society is at
um you know there are all these
questions about you know you know you
know Biden's you know mental acuity and
you know maybe never had that many
marbles to start with but but
um but uh but you know the the version
of it I often wonder about is whether
um you know um his inability to um
address these questions or speak with
them is that actually a feature more
than a bug because
um if you had
if you had sort of a very sharp
liberal person
like I don't like Pete budajig it would
just look ridiculous it was like yeah
you can expect some answers we'd expect
explanations he'd be trying to give us
explanations and they would look so
absurd right and now all we ask is that
he doesn't you know Biden is just
relaxing in a basement that's uh that's
very protective Maybe
you've got to do the best they can do
I guess that's the white pill right it's
like that great I think no I think look
I think I think that but yes and it's
it's it's it's it's it's it's it's uh
yeah I I think there's a there's a lot
of room for
for things to get better you have to
keep up doing the good work you're doing
David well as always it's a pleasure to
talk to you and I do want to uh you know
we do this usually off camera but I do
want to publicly uh give you a thanks
for something because about three years
ago as we sit here in the local studio
now I got on a zoom call with you and
and my partner and locals who's sitting
in the other office right there and we
had an all-cash offer to buy the company
and you basically said to us and I said
Peter it's life-changing money for me do
you think I should do this and you said
basically you said uh if you believe in
it and you get distribution you have a
much bigger opportunity here and we
waited it out we did not take the offer
and then obviously everything happened
with Rumble so uh I owe you on that
front how about that how about that very
good to see you my friend awesome if
you're looking for a more unfiltered
lens into the World of Tomorrow check
out our Tech playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a wide variety
of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of future videos be sure to
subscribe and click notification Bell